a lot of people would say you've got
reason more than most to hate sharks and
yet you don't
can you explain it it was in a spear
fishing championship that I was the
reigning champion it was a six hour
competition
after four hours many fishing things be
it next one had bled into the water and
the tide had gone out but nobody had
seen any sharks and I went out a bit
wider and deeper to try and find fish
that hadn't been scared and as I died
down I was just about to spear a fish
when this huge dump and crash hit me on
the chest
knocked the gun out of my hands and
Basques off my face I was held through
the water then I realized it had to be a
shine and I thought what can I do to
protect myself so I gathered the shark's
head or with my fingers trying to get it
sighs it seemed to let go and as I fell
away I pushed it that shark to try and
push it away but my hand went right in
his mouth ripping I ended up with only
1/10 the left and 94 stitches in my hand
but I grabbed the shark around the
billion still 3040 feet underwater
holding on and then I realized I needed
air as I was snorkeling and I was gonna
drown
I've pushed up to the surface and on the
surface a year that shark shark and I
looked down and the shark was coming
back to attack again
I could see this great being hidden
white teeth coming up through the
blood-red water and I I thought I've got
nothing at all to protect myself I
kicked up the shark but the miracle
happened the shark turned and swallowed
the float that I had to attach two or
three fish to it dived and as it dived
to drag me under water and it I'm on the
road and as it dragged down I tried to
find my belt to get rid of it but I
couldn't find it I couldn't find the
catch and I hadn't breathe deep breathe
much I was just about to gas water and
drown when another miracle happened the
line poked it was severed when the shark
bit me around the Chester who managed to
break as I came up to the surface
yelling out cha-cha-cha
a boat actually had seen the bright red
water my blood and was coming over to
investigate they quickly picked me up
rolled me into the boat and was really
great precision I was in the hospital
within an hour given blood and luckily
stitched up the photographs that were
taken on the operating table and my
stories went around the world people
wondered whether I'd go back in the
water it was when I was at the Adelaide
Zoo looking at the lion cages that I
came up with the idea I'll make a cage
I'll lower it over the side of the boat
in an area where his great big great
white sharks have it and I'll have a
look for myself to see if I want to go
diving again because I love diving but I
was really scared
we made the first cage and on that first
expedition you know 48 years ago
made the first great white shot films
even that first time that you put the
cage in the water did that cure your
fear not really at all it helped the
first shot that came really looked like
a small submarine or the deadly front
Tom's like a not torpedoes with teeth we
thought maybe the Sharks were interested
in the people inside but then we found
that they would come up and bite on the
cage even when there was no one in it
and what we ended up finding it was the
electrolysis that was set out by the
saltwater on the steel that attracted
them and so now that you've spent so
much time with sharks I mean how do you
feel about them they're a wonderful
interesting animal and even today they
still need help because people still
fear and dread them because they're the
last major predator that will beat you
but with education I think people will
understand that we need them in our
oceans and the four hundred varieties
there's only a handful that may bite
people the more I got interested in
sharks and the more I loved the sea I
was able to return and go abalone diving
all the way along our coastline I spent
16 years and five thousand hours or more
underwater and on those occasions I only
saw three sharks normally they don't
have humans on their menu list they
prefer to stick to their own food thank
goodness they didn't because our long
our beaches make it there'd be a real
smorgasbord if they wanted to mm-hmm a
lot of people would say you've got
reason more than most to hate sharks and
yet you don't can you explain it it's
the anomaly
of the sphere that was generated and
shown to me after my shark attack made
me think going back into the water was a
a real relief and I found it wasn't as
bad as everybody thought so I spent all
my life trying to put sharks in a
different perspective because of that
experience you had because of my
experience
you